- Q, how does it feel to be
back on the Universal lot?
- Oh horrifying,
I had PTSD walking in here.
The setup here that she's referring to
is the way our show works.
I don't know if-
Has anybody seen it?
Give me a big applause.
(applause and cheers)
All right, great.
- All right, before you continue
we'll start here, we'll go left,
we'll make our way to the front.
Give one reason why you like the show, go.
- [Q] We got time, we
got time, we got time.
- It's a ten hour show, we're fine.
- [Q] Catch it online, the
rest of this interview,
me describing the show.
It's just, we go out in public
and we mess around with each other
and we tell, you know
- I know
- And we tell each other what to do
and if you don't do it at
the end of the episode,
you get punishment.
- So go back for the Universal tram story,
'cause I know what it
is but they don't know
what your Universal story is.
- So here at Universal they
have the famous tram ride
that goes around the whole sets and tours.
- This is awesome
- My punishment, it wasn't awesome,
it wasn't awesome at all!
- [Kelly] Y'all are such,
words I can't say on daytime
- So the way that the tram
works is it's like the subway
where if an emergency happens
someone drops their cellphone,
they can pull the thing, stop the ride.
So what they made me do is stop the ride
seven, eight times in an hour.
And the first time people are forgiving,
they're like "Oh poor guy,
he dropped his cellphone".
But then I had to stop
the ride and be like
"Uh could you repeat that?"
And then, by the seventh
time that I pulled that,
people were looking at
me in the eye and be like
"When we get off this
ride, I'm gonna find you,
and I'm gonna kill you".
And that's an actual quote
that somebody said to me
on the Universal tram, it was horrible.
(applause)
It was horrible.
- [Joe] Thank you, thank you.
- For us though, it was a hoot.
- You should take the tour
if you haven't it's so great.
- Like a four-year-old girl was
giving me the middle finger.
It was bad, it was really bad.
- All right, so Joe and Murray,
it's my favorite I love your show.